[Music]
everybody please give me or please join
me in giving a huge round of applause to
Emma Watson Emma Watson everybody so
this is the story of Beauty and the
Beast when his vision cleared the old
beggar was gone in her place was the
most beautiful woman the prince had ever
seen she was floating above him emitting
a dazzling golden light not unlike the
sun's instantly the prince knew exactly
what she was for he had read about such
things
she was an enchantress a woman of magic
who had put him to the test
and he had failed falling to his knees
the prince held up his hands please he
said now to that now the one to beg I'm
sorry enchantress you are welcome in my
castle for as long as you like The
Enchantress shook her head she had seen
enough to know that it was a hollow
apology the prince had no kindness will
love in his heart
magic cost through her and then washed
over the prince the transformation began
instantly the princes body was wracked
with pain his back arched and he groaned
as his body began to grow his jewelry
popped off his clothes ripped the
surrounding guests screamed at the sight
of their host and fled the prince
reached up trying to grasp at a nearby
man's hand but to his horror he
discovered his own hand resembled that
of a monster
the man jumped away and made his escape
along with the others
amid it all The Enchantress calmly
watched her punishment take effect soon
the ballroom was empty save for the
staff the entertainers and a lone dog
that belongs to the diva as they looked
on in shock
the princess transformation became
complete where once there had attacked
there had towered a handsome man now
cowered a hideous beast but he was not
the only one to have transformed the
rest of the castle and its inhabitants
no longer look the same
they too had changed the day is bled
into years and the prince and his
servants were forgotten by the world
until finally the enchanted castle stood
isolated and locked in perpetual winter
The Enchantress I raised all memory of
the castle and those who were in it even
from the minds of the people who loved
them but there did remain one last bit
of hope the Rose she had offered the
prince was truly an enchanted rose
enchanted Rose if the castle could learn
sorry if sorry if the prince could learn
to love another and earn that person's
love in return by the time the last
petal fell the spell would be broken if
not he would be doomed to remain a beast
forever thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]